[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to episode
182 of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Jonathan
Foust, and I'm here
with my colleague,
Michelle Casbon.
Hey, Michelle.
How are you doing?
MICHELLE CASBON: Hey, Don.
I'm great.
How are you?
JON FOUST: I'm
doing pretty well.
It's a really long
week, but I'm really
excited for a lot of things that
are happening this week in E3.
And I'm really
excited to hear what
you guys have to talk
about today with Paco
Nathan from Derwin AI.
Paco with us a little
bit about the work
he's doing in AI, big data,
and cloud, and a little bit
about bias in ML.
And we are joined by special
guest, Amanda Casari,
so that seems exciting.
MICHELLE CASBON: It is.
It was a really
great segment to do.
I'm pretty excited to
hear how it turned out.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Well, you have a bunch of
cool things for the week,
but I will tease the question
of the week, which is last week,
we got to see StadiaConnect.
And it answered a
bunch of questions
that developers have had at our
gaming conferences that Mark
and I have been attending.
So I'll be going into a
little bit of the detail
that we got to hear there.
MICHELLE CASBON: All
right, but first,
let's talk about the
coolest things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jon, what was the coolest
thing about this week?
JON FOUST: CERN recreated
the Higgs discovery on GCP.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
JON FOUST: Yeah, you might
have a little bit more detail
on that.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, so this actually
happened a couple weeks ago.
So I am just getting
back from my trip
to Europe, where I got
to visit CERN in person.
And I was really blown away.
I went to KubeCon Barcelona, and
there were a few engineers up
on stage.
They gave a keynote
where they recreated
the discovery of the Higgs
boson on Google Cloud.
So we'll link to a video.
Check it out.
It was really amazing.
They essentially reproduced
the entire discovery within I
believe it was four to
five minutes on stage,
so you can see that happening.
But what was really
cool is being
able to visit in
person, obviously, so
after I got to see it on stage.
CERN is such a good
partner for Google Cloud
because they've always
had this open data policy.
But before public
clouds existed,
they weren't really sure, so
not many people could really
do anything with the data sets
that they uploaded because not
many people had access to
the types of data centers
that they have access to.
So if you are interested in
discovering the Higgs yourself,
they've uploaded
that entire data set.
Check out the CERN
Open Data portal
if you want to recreate
their experiment on your own.
But I wanted to share
some really fun facts.
I got to visit ATLAS, which
is one of seven experiments.
There are seven in total
for main experiments.
ATLAS is a general
purpose experiment.
It's the largest.
And I didn't get to
see these other ones,
but there's also CMS--
also general purpose--
ALICE, LHCb, and
a few other ones.
So it was really interesting
to see it in person,
to see what a collider
looks like when it's
a few feet in front of you.
But some of the really
cool things I learned--
the Large Hadron
Collider was built
on the French-Swiss border.
And so the border actually
runs right across the property,
and the majority of the LHC is
actually on the French side.
And what's interesting about
that when you go to visit,
if you want to get money
out of a Swiss ATM,
you can only do that on
one side of the property
because Swiss banks can only
exist within Switzerland.
The other cool
thing that I liked--
did you know that CERN was
the birthplace of the web?
JON FOUST: I did not
actually know that.
MICHELLE CASBON: So I got to
visit the building where it all
began.
So I got to see the data center.
There are some very large
transcontinental interconnects
that essentially end at CERN.
It was really neat to be there.
So not only was it the site of
the announcement of the Higgs
particle, but also
birth of the web.
JON FOUST: Whoa.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, it is
a really interesting space
to be in.
But my sort of burning
question for this physicist--
I could ask her anything, and
the question that I ask is--
so the Large Hadron
Collider takes protons,
and it sends them off
into opposing directions
so that they collide together.
And my question was
where do the protons come
from that these beams
are composed of?
And her answer was, it's
a canister of hydrogen.
And there's some really
interesting math behind that.
It's a really small
canister, like,
the size of maybe your
forearm, so very small.
You can actually see it in
person if you go to visit.
And that will essentially
power the LHC in perpetuity.
So I'll add a link
to some of the math,
but it's essentially just
taking hydrogen atoms,
splitting them up so that
they're just a single proton,
and sending them on
a collision course.
I thought that was
really interesting.
I expected some very
complicated process for, like,
yanking protons out.
But it's actually very simple.
JON FOUST: Nice.
I can tell by the
excitement in your voice
that you had a really good time.
And for our listeners,
can you tell them
what CERN actually stands
for, just in case none of them
actually know?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, I
believe it's the European Center
for Nuclear Research.
So they're doing
high-energy physics,
smashing protons together.
So the Higgs discovery
was so important
because it helps
us understand what
happened after the Big Bang.
It helps us to understand
the world around us.
And they're doing some really
important research there.
If you want to follow up,
again, the Open Data portal,
if you want to look at
any of that data sets,
that's a good place to start.
Also they sent a Google Street
View camera through there.
So if you want to see what the
CERN control center looks like,
you can do that via Street View.
It's a really cool perspective.
But also one of the
best ways to see it
is to watch the documentary
called "Particle Fever."
That was one of my first
introductions to CERN
is watching the video.
And that essentially,
it's a documentary
of the explanation of the
announcement of the Higgs
particle.
So I thought that was
really interesting.
JON FOUST: That's cool.
Do you happen to know which GCP
products they were using when
they recreated the discovery?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, they
describe it all in the video.
And I believe they
were using Google Cloud
Storage, Kubernetes Engine, and
Memorystore is the other GCP
product that they're using.
And what I didn't know--
I figured this out
at KubeCon when
I spoke with them afterwards--
they're also using Kubeflow.
Did you know that CERN has been
using Kubeflow for over a year?
They're one of our oldest users.
JON FOUST: I actually
didn't know that.
I actually, at Next,
staffed the Kubeflow booth,
and that's where I got my
first introduction to Kubeflow.
So it's kind of amazing to
see that CERN is actually
using Kubeflow for
recreating this discovery.
It's kind of awesome.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
And I'm very excited.
So that's part of
why I was there,
because I went and I talked to
them about some of their newer
Kubeflow uses.
And they have some really,
really exciting ideas.
And I'm hoping to be able to
work with them in the future
to do even more
with the platform.
It's very exciting.
JON FOUST: Well, Michelle,
that was definitely awesome.
So let's just jump right in
with Paco and our surprise
guest, Amanda, and see
what you guys talked
about at Next a
couple of months back.
So let's hear what
they have to say.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Huge welcome
to a few of our guests today.
We have Paco Nathan, managing
partner for Derwin AI.
And we also have
Amanda Casari here.
She's an engineer
on Google Cloud.
We work very closely together.
These are two people that
are very close to my heart.
I've known them both
for a few years.
And I'm honored to have
them both here today.
Thank you for joining us.
AMANDA CASARI: Thank you.
Super excited.
PACO NATHAN: Thank
you so much, Michelle.
This is great.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
you're here at Cloud Next.
What are some of the
most exciting GCP tools
that you've been
working with recently?
PACO NATHAN: Oh, fantastic.
Well, definitely, our
company runs on GCP.
And I would kind of roll
back and reference--
there's a paper
called the "Berkeley
View" about serverless, so
the Dave Patterson paper.
Really, Eric Jonas--
shout out to Eric
and the whole team there, my
former boss Ion Stoica, et
cetera.
They did a paper,
like, 10 years ago
trying to describe
what they thought
cloud was going to be after
about three years of use cases.
And I was invited to
comment on the paper
and did a guest lecture.
And that led to tools
like Apache Spark.
The grad students who created
Spark were in the audience
and were talking about it.
And so 10 years to the
day, they have put together
another paper.
A lot, again, I
mention Eric Jonas
doing PyWren, NumPyWren,
et cetera, all the work
around Ray, and really
trying to understand
the fundamental economics
of how does serverless
change this landscape.
And so they're using serverless
as kind of a bigger umbrella
term.
It's really thinking about
the large scale services.
Like I use Cloud Storage a lot.
I use Datastore.
These are kind of things where
I don't have to run a server.
And so that complexity
in state is just off
of our operations list.
And I would
reference that paper.
It's like drop what you're
doing and go read that paper.
And there's a really
great blog post
by Ion Stoica comparing
the two of them.
So that's what
I'm excited about.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
I know the conference
has just kicked off,
but the highlight for me
so far has been having
you moderate our session.
PACO NATHAN: Thank
you very kindly.
Thank you, Michelle.
And you all did a
fantastic session there.
I loved the theme.
I loved the big reveal and
the outcome following up
from the session, too.
Maybe we could talk
about that some, too.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, I would love
to hear your favorite
part of the session, why
you think it's important.
And let's tell people
a little bit more
about what that big reveal was.
PACO NATHAN: So
really, well, there
were really two parts that
really popped out at me.
I mean, obviously, one
is just the richness
of what's going on in
Kubeflow and what you can do,
especially the auto scaling
parts that you demoed.
Really, really
fantastic work there.
I'm learning more and more
about this every time I look,
but just the amount
of management
of internal
microservices and what's
being exposed externally.
I've been working a lot
with workflow tooling,
and so I was really happy to see
what's going on with Kubeflow.
But then in the context
also of Quicksilver
and what John Bohannon and their
team at Primer has been doing,
the other part of
this, of course,
was understanding
human bias at scale
and looking at new sources,
comparing that with Wikipedia,
and just the fantastic work
in highlighting where there's
bias, but also how to fix it.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
They're doing some
really amazing things.
It was one of my
favorite projects
to be able to take
that amazing MLP work
and put it into Kubeflow.
It combined two things that
I'm just super interested in.
So you have been
pretty busy recently.
You're very well known
in the data science space
and have your own projects now.
Tell us a little bit about
what you've been working on.
PACO NATHAN: Sure.
I'm at a company called Derwen.
And we do a lot of
machine learning work.
We haven't announced it.
Maybe I could just make the
big reveal on the podcast.
MICHELLE CASBON:
That'd be great.
PACO NATHAN: Yeah, so
we're doing a lot of work,
a lot of tooling for
developer relations,
and particularly ways that
machine learning can be used.
In use cases that are related
to DevRel, certainly taking
a look at the whole
art of performance
that's associated with going
out and speaking at conferences,
meetups, et cetera.
And a lot more teaching
tools, I guess,
kind of go along with
it, but with a focus
toward the communities
that are engaged.
So we've been working
on that, and we
have a small team
together now, and been
pulling together clients, and
rolling out some products.
So hopefully, you'll
see more of that later.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's amazing.
This is the best location
for you to be right now.
PACO NATHAN: I appreciate it.
MICHELLE CASBON: We've
been collecting data points
of things that we can improve.
And all of your hard work
will pay off, I'm sure.
PACO NATHAN: Wonderful.
There's another project,
too, I could mention.
My colleague Ben Lorca
at O'Reilly Media,
we just got done doing
three large surveys.
So it was really interesting.
It's what we're calling ABC,
so AI, Big data, and Cloud.
And we were looking at
across-the-world adoption
for ABC, and in particular,
taking a contrast between
companies that are more mature--
maybe they've been doing
machine learning and production
for, like, five years--
versus companies that
are just-- they've
been in it for a
couple of years--
they're figuring it out,
versus companies that
really haven't started yet.
It's like what's the
contrast between those?
What do companies
learn once they
start adopting cloud, and
adopting a lot of the tooling,
and then deploying
machine learning?
MICHELLE CASBON: And what are
some of the biggest surprises
you found in that survey?
PACO NATHAN: There was
a couple of things.
I mean, one is we
were struggling
with how to understand
investments and budget.
And we had a multiple
choice, like are you
putting 5% of your budget
toward machine learning, 10%,
blah blah.
And we had this catch-all
at the end, 20% or more.
And we're like, OK, nobody's
going to check that.
And it turns out that when you
look at the mature practices,
they're really doubling down.
So for 2019, 43%
of enterprise said
they're investing 20% or
more of their total IT budget
into machine learning projects.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow, that is
a lot more than I expected.
PACO NATHAN: Yeah, startling.
And also just the
range, just the kinds
of applications-- like half
the organizations we surveyed
were already using
deep learning.
And a third were using some
form of human-in-the-loop active
learning.
One quarter were already
working with Knowledge Graph.
That kind of shocked me.
This study, I know there was
a lot of people from finance.
But we were surprised
to see one-fifth
saying that they're
starting work
with reinforcement learning.
And so portfolio management is
coming in, but also customer
support and other areas.
And I think the
biggest thing when
you look at the gap between
the mature companies in machine
learning versus the
ones that are still
trying to figure it
out, transfer learning
is used at about 3x.
So a really big bubble
on transfer learning.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
So as you see so many
people adopting this--
I mean, 20% of IT budgets at
large companies in 40% of--
PACO NATHAN: That's
serious money.
MICHELLE CASBON:
That's serious money.
And something like that
can be quite dangerous
if we don't have the
right safeguards in place.
PACO NATHAN: Exactly.
Kind of roll back a little bit,
I was co-chair for JupyterCon.
And one of the real
surprises last year
was in Project Jupyter, a lot
of the uptick was enterprise.
And what we found is
that large organizations
are rolling out open source.
They're running either on-prem,
but more and more in the cloud
or hybrid in some way.
But they're using Jupyter
for infrastructure,
for data science, so
teams can work together
and executives can
see the results.
So that kind of collaborative
infrastructure based partly
on Jupyter is also
going back to Kubeflow.
It's pretty much part
and parcel there.
We're seeing it
across the board,
and we're really
surprised that it
was in the regulated
environments
that there was
more of an uptick.
Capital One is really
a good example.
Two Sigma is another
Wall Street firm.
Inside DOD, PayPal, Netflix--
a lot of sort of
digital infrastructure
is relying more and more.
And the thing that
struck out is, like,
once you deploy these kinds
of collaborative tools,
and you start working
with data science
across the organization,
the things that pop out
are the business issues,
the safety issues.
You were talking about it.
It's like, how do we collaborate
well as opposed to badly?
What are the security issues?
What's the data privacy issues?
What are the ethical issues?
And just the whole spectrum
of compliance that comes in
is, like, as soon as you
can get that collaborative
infrastructure out
there, you come back
to the human issues, the
real business issues.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
and those are really
structures that we
need to put in place
as humans to protect us
from things going wild
and computers
taking over, right?
PACO NATHAN: Yeah.
And one thing that I've seen
over the past year or two
in the field is
there's a lot of sort
of debate about
friction or tension
between data engineering
and data science.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm very
familiar with that tension.
PACO NATHAN: No, I
mean, it's a good topic.
There's a lot of good
issues there to explore.
There are some
companies that say
you have to have five data
engineers for every data
scientist.
And then you go to Stitch Fix,
and they're like, no, no, no,
let's do it the
other way around--
or even more, right?
They have a lot of
data scientists.
So one thing there,
though, that we
find is once you deploy machine
learning models in production,
you get business
issues that come back
to the real human element.
Models degrade once they
hit live customer data.
You have to figure that out.
Trying to understand why
they're acting differently
than they did with
the training set
is often a very challenging
statistical problem, probably
more statistics than most
data science teams will have.
And it's also it's
at that point where
you start hitting the ethical
issues, bias issues that
will cause the regulators
to come knocking.
And the other thing, too, is
I'm helping mentor someone over
in London ICL, a researcher
working on attack
vectors for deep learning.
And you can inject a very
tiny little bit of noise
and throw off models.
So the whole attack surface
is just really not well
understood yet.
And you take all of those
kind of safety factors
into consideration.
You have to have
the right tooling.
the right process.
But you have to have
the right culture, too.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, and one
of the ways that you can help
is to have good data
governance policies.
You've been doing some
work in that space, right?
PACO NATHAN: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, that was something
else that came out
of the surveys
was we asked, what
are your priorities for
investing in projects?
Where are you really
focusing your attention?
And of course, in enterprise,
sort of what you would expect--
the devil you know--
data preparation,
feature engineering.
These are hard problems
that are always
going to be there, at
least for the near future.
But then you get down to like
the fourth item in the list,
and it was data
governance, followed
by metadata management,
followed by lineage.
It was a bunch of
governance issues.
And so companies are really
taking this into account.
One thing I didn't
share, we were
surprised by how many
enterprise companies have
checklists for ethics, and bias,
and privacy before you deploy.
So companies are
really taking to heart
that they have to
do the right thing,
or they'll be in trouble.
So governance is the
larger issue there.
And governance has been
around since the '90s.
And it was all sort
of focused on data
warehouses and SQL
for a long time.
But I guess about
2012, you start
to see some of the first firms
doing big data data governance.
Like, Alation, I think,
was one of the early ones.
And now you've got a real
healthy cohort of startups.
A couple are public now.
Private equity has taken
over a few that are larger.
But it's a really
difficult thing
to understand how do
I have the governance
in the cloud versus
on-prem, versus at the edge,
the mobile apps, the data
partnering that's going on.
It's a super complex
landscape, and security issues
are becoming more
and more complex.
Yeah, I don't think that there's
a lot of clear answers yet,
but there are a lot
of good questions.
MICHELLE CASBON: It's great
to hear that companies
have pre-flight checklists.
I didn't realize so many
people were doing that,
and that's typically
good to hear.
PACO NATHAN: While
we're talking,
I can probably get
some numbers on that.
We would call it robust
model building checklists.
And definitely,
there's this contrast
where you see much
more emphasis on this
in the mature
companies as opposed
to the companies that are just
starting to figure it out.
And so I think that
the industry is
having a pretty healthy reaction
to some of what's happened.
But definitely, "Wall Street
Journal" called 2018--
I don't have the
exact language here,
but it was basically a
total meltdown globally,
as far as data governance.
I mean, we had so many breaches,
so many privacy problems
that involved, in some cases,
hundreds of millions of people.
In Asia, there was
a very notable one.
Also things with Facebook, and
elections, and all the rest--
it really brought
to light how much we
have to take into account
that our governments forget.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, because
as platforms like Kubeflow
make it easier to
spin up models,
we really have to be careful
about the types of models
that we release out into
the world, what we're
doing with them, and
how we're keeping
track of where the
data came from that
went into those models.
PACO NATHAN: Although
I think that there's
a natural pairing there.
I mean, it sounds
like the emphasis
on developing checklists and
developing culture around
that could fit very well with
a lot of the process that
naturally comes out of
Kubeflow and how you manage.
There are open-source
projects like Aeon
and others that try to
integrate some of this thinking
into your development
and deployment process.
So I'm hopeful that these two
kind of meet in the middle.
AMANDA CASARI: As we're
looking and you're
talking about how
people are spending
budget, when you talk about
checklists, that's processes.
When you talk about people,
and resources, and tooling,
how do you think the most
sophisticated, advanced
companies are
approaching splitting up
that budget between
people, processes,
and tooling to be successful
for all the challenges and risks
that you're seeing approaching?
PACO NATHAN: We tried
to qualify and quantify
some the answers to this.
And I put together a
diagram that's basically
a survival analysis of that.
So if you look at
those three buckets
that we're using
for our dimensions,
there's the companies
that are the leaders that
are more mature.
They've been getting
return on investment
for machine learning for
a period of years already.
And then there's
the companies that
are just kind of evaluating.
They're figuring it out.
They've been in for
a few years now,
but they still struggle some.
And then there's the companies,
probably 50% or more,
that are real nonstarters.
They don't get past.
So I think it's in the
survival analysis, if you will,
where you can see where the
budgets are effective and where
they aren't.
And so for the laggard
group that are nonstarters,
they usually struggle
with tech debt.
And so that's one characteristic
that is pervasive.
Their data infrastructure
has so much technical debt
that it's hard to
get accessibility
to the data across divisions, so
you still have a lot of silos.
And that kind of goes back
to the original problem
of data science
breaking down the silos.
The other two points for the
laggards are people problems.
So one is a company culture
that doesn't recognize the need
for better data infrastructure,
or data science,
or machine learning.
And that's generally
from the top.
Davos World Economic
Forum recognized
that as one of the crucial
issues for Davos 2019
was looking across the board.
Speaking of board, board
members and executive staff--
they're where you
run into problems
where they don't recognize
the need for machine learning.
They know that their
competitors are using it.
They know that
regulators are going
to ask difficult questions.
They don't know how to
confront it directly.
So yeah, it's the people problem
of training and education,
whatever you want to say.
And the third point is
also a people problem.
A lot of companies struggle with
identifying business use cases,
even if they're right
in front of them.
And so that's more a
matter of awareness
and learning about
use cases, but it's
kind of a product
manager problem.
So I would say that for
the ones that are really
fumbling in the 54%, it
really does come down
to tech debt versus culture.
When you get into the mainstream
companies that are trying,
what they find is
talent gap, so hiring.
And that's the big
people problem.
They also have a lot
of data quality issues
that they're still
struggling with.
That's always going to be there.
But there are priorities
for where do you
put your investment?
Do you launch a new AI project?
Do you do something
else that's strategic?
What are the
concerns going to be
for security and other risks?
And they kind of
struggle with those.
So those are kind of the
three dimensions there.
MICHELLE CASBON: So related
to what you just talked about,
hiring is hard, so
the people problems
of being able to find
data scientists that
are experienced
enough to understand
the full implications of the
products that they're building.
Do you have any
ideas for ways we
could put the proper
safeguards in place,
so like automated ways of
maybe teaching younger data
scientists and being able to
be more conscious of that?
PACO NATHAN: Very good
question, and everybody's
struggling with it.
McKinsey, and
Deloitte, and the rest
are publishing articles
about how hard this is
and how much everybody
is struggling.
I mean, there are definitely
some excellent proofs,
like Berkeley's
program Data 101,
where Berkeley now has
data science programs that
are required for
all undergraduates
that actually
currently touch, like,
80% of the student
population at Berkeley.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
Is that any student or just
computer science programs?
PACO NATHAN: No, no, no.
I mean across the board.
The chancellor came in
and said, thou shalt
have data science
as a requirement.
And oh, by the way, build up
conduits into social studies,
into hard sciences, everywhere.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
PACO NATHAN: So that's good.
It's something that requires a
lot of infrastructure at scale.
It's not sure how
that percolates down
to Kansas State University.
I don't mean to pick on them.
I actually like
Manhattan, Kansas.
But there's a lot
of other schools
that maybe don't have 100 IT
people on staff like Berkeley
would.
So that's a question of how do
we level that playing field?
Does the NSF get in and
sort of cookie cutter
successful programs
across the board?
There have been studies about
the contrast of how Canada
has tried to roll out pervasive
data science education
versus how the US has.
And the story is in the US,
it's really more concentrated
in the big schools.
Canada was a little bit
more uniform about it.
In general, I would lean more
towards for the people who
are working right now
and need to be really
conscious of the problems
we have today about ethics,
about bias, about how we're
using data, about security,
they can't really afford
to stop everything and go
get a bachelor's degree, right?
So I would reference Amy
Heineke, one of our friends
who had the great phrase,
data science is a team sport.
And so I think that if you
go through that lens where
there's a lot of people who are
going to be working with these
kind of systems and problems--
and I don't even call myself
a data scientist--
I think that a lot of
people work in teams
where these are the kinds
of tooling and issues
process that we have.
And a lot more people
need to be brought up
to speed on how to
participate in a team.
But the thing that's been
the real success out of data
science is the diversity,
is the fact that it's
inherently interdisciplinary.
And having people with
radically different views
of the workplace
working side by side
are how you knock down the
hard problems that would
have been siloed otherwise.
So I think I would
be in favor of how
can people learn these skills.
And I'm super excited to
see the uptick in Python,
the uptick in Jupyter--
a lot of very accessible tooling
to get very professional work
done.
MICHELLE CASBON:
As part of my talk,
I showed Kubeflow
running Jupyter.
And I mentioned that
the very first time
I saw a Jupyter notebook
was in Paco's workshop.
PACO NATHAN: That was fun.
MICHELLE CASBON: So everything
I learned about notebooks,
I have you to thank for that.
PACO NATHAN: Thank you kindly.
I'm very happy about
what's been going on
in the Jupyter community.
And there's great
mentoring programs
that are adjacent to this.
Some of what's
happened out of what's
now called the
Carpentries, but basically
mentoring programs for
teaching people in research,
and then teaching them how to
teach other people in research.
And I think that by
and large, mentoring
is a requirement
for data science,
especially in enterprise.
The techniques go
stale very quickly.
You have to be doing
continuous learning.
And part of the way you do that
as professionals is to build up
your network of people
who can help you
learn what's important.
And the best way to
do that is to mentor.
So if you're out in
industry right now,
and you want to
know how to build up
this kind of capability
in your organization,
look at the mentoring programs
because it's also a big win
for diversity and inclusion.
It's a healthy thing
for organizations.
And I think it's really the only
answer, given the numbers when
you talk about training
for data science.
MICHELLE CASBON: I agree there.
I know my career has
really been transformed
once I found great female
mentors, especially
in the data science space.
AMANDA CASARI: I love how
you mention the team sport
aspect and the
cross-collaborative aspect
for bringing people
up to the next level.
I think it's interesting
how both of you
were talking about training
at the academic level
and training at the
beginning of people's careers
are transition points
for their careers.
But as you addressed a lot of
the risks and challenges people
were facing, Paco, I think you
were talking more about where
companies have
top-down management
or have hierarchical
organizations,
and have teams that operate and
do decision-making that way.
And for some organizations
and verticals,
that works very well.
How do we look at and
give advice for people,
as they're thinking
about transforming
their organizations, to be more
reactive and proactive when
issues come up, as to how they
shape their organizations to be
able to work in this active
learning and this leveling
space where they're really
facing the challenges head on,
rather than waiting
for someone to come
tell them they have a problem?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, and
to support this mentoring
model and really just
proactively getting
after these challenges.
AMANDA CASARI: Yes, exactly.
And across organizations, not
just with a data science team,
but with the entire business
decision-making system
that exists within a company.
PACO NATHAN: So there's
a kind of a catch phrase
that's being used in
the industry now called
the unbundling of
decision-making.
And it's the idea
that OK, top-down
worked in some places,
top-down decision-making.
But now we're finding that
enterprise organizations
are large.
They're very diverse.
They're distributed.
You can't rely on top-down
control structures.
So you have to have more
collaborative ways of teams
to arrive at decisions.
And part of that is also just
the influx of machine learning.
Now we have teams of
people and machines.
So how do we manage that?
There's a really
fantastic article about it
from Ajay Agrawal.
It was on "McKinsey Quarterly."
It's called "The Economics
of Artificial Intelligence."
But he really
unpacks that notion
of unbundling of
decision-making.
And also I believe
somebody at Google,
the chief decision
scientist for Google Cloud,
Cassie Kozyrkov--
really fantastic work.
Her lectures, I've gotten to
catch couple of those, also
about sort of decision
engineering and how--
what Cassie was
showing is Google
is coming out and
saying, hey, look, we've
learned from some mistakes.
And this is really a better way.
And I think that's an
important thing to have,
because what better
touchstone could you reference
for using AI than Google?
But yet, organizations
still have to learn.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, Cassie is
one of our favorite colleagues.
We're very lucky to have her.
She's part of our group.
PACO NATHAN: Ah, fantastic.
AMANDA CASARI: And I think it
goes back to conversations.
It's funny you were
talking, Michelle,
about your introduction to Paco.
My introduction to Paco
was a shared interest
in control systems
and complex systems.
So we had a lot of conversations
around how initial data sites'
pipelines were
designed around DAGs,
in Directed Acyclic Graphs,
which did not actually take
into account feedback loops.
And it sounds now like we're
progressing to that point
where we can get both
systems design as well
as the computational design
to be able to incorporate
decisive loops within there
to be able to allow humans
and machines to be able
to question decision
points along the way.
I find that very encouraging and
fascinating at the same time.
PACO NATHAN: You know what?
There's kind of three
dimensions there.
I think there are feedback
loops that are inherently
two-way streets if done right.
And they involve the
people in your organization
who have a deep bench
of the use cases,
they have the
institutional learning,
and they train other
people to come in, right?
That's, again, getting back
to the team sport aspect.
There's the models, which are
being updated, but curated.
And then there's
also the customers.
And so there's interaction
between the customers
and the models, right,
and your product,
but also between your
people and your customers.
And also there's interaction
between your people
and the models.
So how can you
engineer or really
facilitate those kind
of feedback loops
in a way that's very
beneficial for all involved?
AMANDA CASARI: And
I think that was
the point of your talk today,
Michelle, was looking at where
decisions happen inside
of a very complex system,
and then trying to make
sure that you understand
when your outcome
is not reflective
of a more holistic structure.
How do you add something
to that system,
so that it can make
better outcomes that
is more representative of the
people, and the population,
and the customers that
you want to serve?
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
I mean, I think so
many times, we sort of
blame ML for coming up
with these biased outcomes.
But the models are
subject to the data
that we feed into them.
And it takes human
decisions to overcome
that to build the
type of model that
can work around that bias,
that can accommodate it.
If we never make human
decisions to do that,
then we'll get the same
outcomes every single time.
And so it is very
much a human problem.
We can't blame the machines.
Humans are creating the
code that creates this.
And all of that data is based
on generations of human bias.
And it's up to us
to look at things
from a different perspective
and to take an active role
in changing that.
PACO NATHAN: Well,
in your talk, you
were discussing about structural
bias and how some of this
is so subtle and
nuanced, you can't really
point to here's rule 531
that causes the problem.
But instead, it's
this interaction
of a lot of complex rule systems
that we just delegate to.
And that in large
quantities at scale,
that's what leads to the
really terrible cases of bias.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
These little, small
things accumulate.
When you're talking about
just a small group of people,
it's not always
obvious, or maybe it is.
But when you extrapolate
out to millions of people,
that's where it just
becomes very glaring,
and it excludes whole
groups of people.
And you can use machine learning
to identify that in a way that
as a human, you couldn't.
You can use machine learning
to sort of tease out
what those examples
are and then use
it to help you build something
that accommodates that.
But these are all
human decisions.
It's very much a cop-out
to blame machine learning
for being biased when we're
the ones who are building
these systems, who are
coming up with the concepts
and using them to solve
very specific problems.
We're the ones defining
those problems.
AMANDA CASARI: And we're
part of that system then.
So when we define ourselves
as separate from it,
we're trying to
remove responsibility
from the decisions we're
making along the way.
PACO NATHAN: Getting back
to the control systems.
AMANDA CASARI: Yes, but if we
inject ourselves back as a node
into that decision-making
process, when
we find that there are errors or
problems, the solution to that
may not always be more data,
better data, different data.
It may not be a different
component in the algorithm.
It may be that you
have to allow trust
for users, or customers,
or yourself-- the people
who are creating those
systems-- and to place that back
into a large
distributed network,
and being able to
identify that and identify
what is the right problem
that you're trying to solve.
Is the answer a person?
Is the answer an
algorithm adjustment?
Or is the answer a different
computational structure?
It's all very important.
And I think we're reaching
a good stage where
we can start to make those
blended answers as opposed
to always looking for a
different parameter value
to fix.
PACO NATHAN: Michelle,
also I really
liked what you're describing.
I think it's important
to think of machine
learning and supervised machine
learning not just as a way
to predict, but as a lens.
And so can we use it as a lens
to understand contrast and then
begin to understand our
own structural biases more?
That's something that is
probably not taught in courses
about machine learning.
But I think as we dig more into
the real cultural problems that
are coming to light, it will be.
Well, Amanda, you brought
up a really good point
about control systems.
I think that Margaret
Mead probably
is one of the better authors
in this area from, like, 60,
70 years ago.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wait, can
you say that name again?
I didn't catch it.
PACO NATHAN: Margaret Mead.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Oh, Margaret Mead.
PACO NATHAN:
Anthropology studies
leading to second-order
cybernetics, the Macy
conferences.
Really fantastic
work back there.
So I think that we
need to look back
into our own history,
intellectual history.
Some of the bridges that
have already been crossed
can really inform
the social problems
we're running into now.
I mean, a lot of what
we run into daily
about bias and problems
with machine learning--
Marshall McLuhan set out
this incredibly strange book
called "The Gutenberg
Galaxy" back in 1960.
And it's actually kind of
hard to read, but really,
really fascinating to read.
But I mean, he just laid it out.
I could tell here's
where it's all
going to kind of go sideways.
And he didn't even live to see
the internet, but he nailed it.
So I think between Margaret
Mead, and Marshall McLuhan,
and Russell, and
some of the others,
there's a lot that we can draw.
AMANDA CASARI: Yeah, I think
that there's wonderful reading
lists that we can have
from historical technology.
Marie Hicks, the book she
wrote on programming inequality
and talking about looking at
how women were systemically
taken out of an entire
industry in a country
is very eye-opening
and wonderful for us
to understand how do
these decisions propagate.
And then even should you change
that initial decision point,
how does it continue to
move through these larger
distribution systems that the
effects are felt at a much
larger time scale than
you originally understood
they would or could be?
I think those are awesome use
cases and historical examples
for us to be able to look at
to understand when we first
started automating
decision systems,
when we first started
creating things
that we wanted to make a little
bit quicker controls in order
to be able to move us
along with machines
when we had human
machine interactions,
how did those first
decisions get made?
What were the
implications of those?
When we changed that initial
decision that was made,
how did it continue to
move through the rest
of our culture?
And what should we
be learning from that
as we're looking at
creating systems that scale?
And I love how you talked
about that, Michelle,
that we're giving
the people tools
to automatically scale and
globally scale their systems,
globally scale their products.
And we want to be
able to do that,
but we also want to be able to
make sure that we are keeping
up with responsibility decision
frameworks along the way
and computational tools
that will allow people
to know when those systems
are being used responsibly,
when they are--
I think as you were
talking about, Paco--
when the risk factors are
being examined appropriately,
or if people are
using them in a way
they didn't originally intend
that system to be used,
and letting the creators know
that as early as possible
so that they can take action
on what's happening with it.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
and as much as possible,
trying to bake that
into the framework
so that it's just, by default,
there for everyone as easily
as the technologies
that enable it.
AMANDA CASARI: For
everybody, right?
I love how you say that
because this is what Kubeflow
is, is an open source project.
And we want to make sure
those frameworks are
available to all,
and just not a few.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wonderful.
This has been amazing.
Thank you both for
sitting down with us.
It has been amazing
having you both here.
Thank you for joining us.
Paco Nathan from Derwen,
is there any last things
you'd like to plug?
PACO NATHAN: No, just I'm
really looking forward
to wandering around
here at Next.
It's really fascinating.
Maybe catch some more talks.
MICHELLE CASBON: It's wonderful.
Thank you again for taking so
much time out of your schedule
to join us here.
And thank you again, Amanda,
for joining us today.
This has been one of the most
fun podcast episodes I've ever
done to have two of my
friends all together talking
data science.
I really appreciate it.
What has been the best part
of Next for you, Amanda?
AMANDA CASARI: Well,
this is my first Next.
And so far, the
best part for me has
been seeing all of
the amazing hard work
that I've seen so many
passionate people who really
care about creating
things for developers,
and creating things
for customers,
and for really creating
tooling that will allow
so many people to just create
whatever is in their mind,
to create their dreams and to be
able to carry that out in a way
where they don't
have to consider
every small piece along the
way they may not be expert in,
but that they're happy
to get expertise and help
from other people.
So really identifying and seeing
all of these individual pieces
come together with people, and
with work, and the releases,
it's just been so
lovely and fascinating.
And also just the
amount of, I think,
culture and care for our
conference, the intentionality
that I've seen all the
organizers put into making sure
that it is an inclusive space
for people to come and ask
questions and talk to everybody
that's here has been wonderful.
MICHELLE CASBON: Well, thank
you both for joining us.
A huge thank you to Paco and
Amanda for joining me at Next.
I really enjoyed
that conversation.
I'm very happy to share it.
So now to our
question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jon, StadiaConnect
happened last Thursday.
What are some of the
biggest announcements
that came out of it?
JON FOUST: I'm pretty
excited about this
because I've been sitting on a
little bit of the information
for a while, but we
couldn't publicly
release this information.
But it's always
good to have that.
Stadia, the way I've
always described
it is being like the
Netflix of video games.
And you can imagine
that your resolution
scales based on your connection,
and Stadia does the same thing.
And one of the things
that developers always
asked at our gaming
conferences is
what is the speed necessary
to render in 4K in the data
centers?
And you just need at least 35
megabytes per second, which
I don't think is
too bad because I
think that's around the
typical amount of down
that you get on your ISPs,
which is kind of awesome.
And it only requires a
minimum of 10 megabytes
per second, which is awesome.
So at 10 megabytes,
you'll get 780p,
and you'll get, I believe,
regular stereo sound.
And at the highest, you'll
get 5.1 surround sound.
Also a bunch of games
were announced as well.
I'm pretty excited
about a bunch of them.
And a lot have been
announced at E3 this week.
So just some notable names, I'm
excited about "Final Fantasy
XV."
"Assassin's Creed Odyssey" is
what's been seen at our demos.
"The Division 2" looked amazing
when they showed it off.
And one of the
things that I think
will be a really big hit in
the home will be "Just Dance."
So that'd be kind of cool.
And the last thing is they
kind of announced the Stadia
Founder's Edition bundle.
It comes with a 4K Chromecast
and a Stadia controller.
It's a special
edition controller,
so you can only get
this as an exclusive
when you get the
founder's edition.
And this comes in blue,
which is kind of cool.
But I'm personally more
excited about the black one.
And there actually was
one more announcement.
They talked about price.
That was one of the
big things that people
wanted to know about.
And for Stadia Pro, it will
cost you $9.99 a month,
which isn't too bad.
That's around the
same amount that you
will pay for your typical
streaming service.
And there also is a
free tier, but that
will be coming next year.
And a lot of these features
and a lot of these products
will be coming out and launch
in, I believe, November.
So I'm really excited
for that to come out.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's
a lot of announcements.
Thanks for sharing.
JON FOUST: I'm super
excited about it.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
So I think that wraps
it up for this week.
So where are we all
going to be this week?
I know I'm back on my
home turf in San Francisco
after my long trip to
Geneva and Barcelona.
Where will you be, Jon?
JON FOUST: Well,
I'll be in New York.
The next conference I'm actually
attending is Games for Change.
We talked about it a little bit
in my last episode with Mark.
But just to remind our
listeners what that is,
it's pretty much
a conference where
developers are creating games
for change, as in the title.
But it has a lot of
social impact games,
breaking down the
barriers between diversity
and being more
inclusive in games.
And developers who are
really focused on that
get to showcase those things.
And I get to actually
attend a couple
talks to see the momentum
shift to actually making
these changes in games.
So I'm pretty excited
to be attending that.
So that will be occurring
for me next week.
Yeah, the week of the 17th.
Yeah.
So I'm pretty excited.
MICHELLE CASBON: Sounds great.
I think most of us are at home.
I know Mark Mirchandani will
be here in San Francisco.
Brian and Aja will
be in Seattle.
And Gabi, I believe she'll
be in Brazil this week.
JON FOUST: I just saw
her off last week,
so she's really excited to
go home and see not only
her family, but she's attending
a couple of conferences
there as well.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, I've
been to Brazil with Gabi.
And she's in her element
when she's down there.
Very excited for her and
jealous that I'm not in Brazil.
JON FOUST: I've been
to South America,
but I'm really, really, really
wanting to go to Brazil.
So hopefully, Gabi will
take me along one day.
MICHELLE CASBON: I recommend it.
It's a great place.
JON FOUST: Well, thank
you all for listening.
And we'll hope to
see you next week.
MICHELLE CASBON: Sounds good.
JON FOUST: Bye.
MICHELLE CASBON: Thanks, Jon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]